welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you too much information about time
travel a plot device so tempting it has
infected all
fiction from the nolan cinematic
universe and superheroes to
game of thrones and hugh jackman
rom-coms
but you know if it's so easy why am i
not
constantly having assassins from the
future trying to sneak up behind me and
kill me
i mean you would think that once you
open that can of worms or
i guess keep that true dinger's cat box
closed all kinds of crazy eventualities
would be theoretically possible but uh i
guess not
i'm eric boss and here with me is the
hilarious nerd and host of correct mundo
on the lra network
hector navarro thank you so much for
having me or should i say
thank you so much for having had me yes
make sure you get that
correct grammatical tense there future
perfect perfect perfect i'm so glad
you're on the show today because
i'm a time travel nerd i know you're a
time travel fiction nerd
we're gonna dive i think deeper into
this hole than anyone else on youtube
ever has i'm ready i'm ready the cinemas
are gradually reopening
as we speak i don't know if that's a
good idea but um
like the technology of time travel it's
a risk that we're inevitably going to
take
fittingly two of the big releases right
now deal with time travel or time
manipulation christopher nolan's tenant
and bill and ted face the music and
tenet especially looks like it's gonna
be changing the game in terms of how
time travel works
in movies nolan is definitely a madman
trying to root his logic in real world
physics
let's figure out how that's gonna work
so what's the big question this week the
big question
is eric what are the different versions
of time travel and which version
gets it the most right according to real
world
physics excellent question oh yes
according to real world physics because
a lot of screenwriters try to do it and
a lot of storytellers fail to do it
uh and hector and i have watched
probably nearly every
or most of the big time travel examples
we've seen in tv film
comics everywhere um and we can boil it
down to there are at least
eight types of time travel we're going
to break them down
and we want to shout out the youtube
channel minutephysics they did an
amazing visual breakdown of alternate
time travel types they created these
lovely graphics we love graphics here
but there are a few big types that they
they left out when they did a couple
years ago
and some distinctions that i think we
need to dive deeper into oh and before
we begin spoiler warning
um because there are some movies out
there that you might not have known our
time travel but the twist of them in the
third act is that they are time travel
stories
so if you have not seen one of these and
care to watch it someday
just uh tread lightly so uh the first
type of time travel we're gonna talk
about hector
is what we are just gonna simply call
the classic [ __ ] it
time travel so this is really the
anything goes approach when it comes to
time travel characters can travel back
and forth within their historical
timeline
and there are inconsistent limits in
logic on that travel
and there's usually some silly magic
device like a delorean a phone booth hot
tub radio toaster et cetera
so the examples of this most famously
back to the future back to the future
marty mcfly uses delorean to
accidentally rewrite history
and it ends up being without him in it
he starts to fade from the timeline but
then he fixes it
to make his future even better his dad
becomes a bully novelist
who enslaves an auto worker marty here's
your keys
you're all waxed up ready for tonight
yeah really wrong lessons learned in
that timeline wrong lessons learned
and i i know we're gonna bring this up
later but then like the rules changing
back to the future part two so this is
so it really is the
time travel trilogy is the back to the
future trilogy
absolutely uh bob gales starts and
zemeck is starting to figure out uh
how to do it correctly as the series
goes also timely bill and ted is a
[ __ ] time travel movie kidnap
historical figures to help with their
history report and then they end up
revising the future so that they're rock
stars and they use george carlin in a
phone booth to do it that's true though
to their credit though to the credit of
the bill and ted scripts
i love the details of bill and ted being
able to do things in their present
by saying we'll just take care of that
in the future and then that's right like
it's like hinted at that we don't see
that on screen or anything but then like
later ted goes to put a tape a cassette
player to distract his dad
and they're like what are we going to
say in it i don't know i'm over here i'm
over here dad because they needed
somebody to distract
their dad in the present so technically
everything still sort of checks out with
bill and ted
and did they rewrite the future or was
that the way it was always going to be
question mark but it is definitely for a
story and you get to see joan of arc
doing jazzercise so it's super fun
that's right
and just because it doesn't mean it's
poorly plotted out bill and ted back to
the future two of her favorite movies of
all time and
honestly some of the best time travel
fiction just because by saying
it you kind of free yourself up just to
have fun and not get lost in the details
get the hell out of my car
old man another example of this and they
were trying to do bill into the modern
era hot tub time machine is the same
kind of thing as bill and ted you know
they just use a hot tub deadpool 2
uses cable's watch and they allow them
to kind of redo the final battle
and then in the post-credits sequence he
like prevents green lantern x-men
origins tries to kill baby hitler so
it's just kind of silly
it's like a cartoon uh speaking of
cartoons simpsons the uh treehouse of
horror five
uh the time of punishment um he
accidentally sneezes on a dinosaur
and then category scrambles into the
future into like an orwellian
all kinds of crazy madness stupid bug
you go squish now it's
just the funniest example of what we're
talking about is the simpsons
homer being like oh remember what your
dad said on your wedding day if you ever
travel back in time
don't step on anything and i always love
that uh whatever that is an anteater
it's just like
it's your favorite thing let's talk
about 11 22
63 this is the stephen king book that
they turn into a james franco series
this one's crazy and i love it they use
the magic seller they go back to the 50s
to try to prevent the jfk assassination
but what's cool about this is because
it's a stephen king universe like fate
intervenes it makes it really really
hard to change the timeline drastically
and then when they do change the
timeline you know even worse fate plays
out but
i would still categorize this in the
category just because
you know it's all set within one
timeline where you know there are plot
holes if you look to our
magic seller yeah yeah yeah of course uh
you know a lot you trekkies are like
wait there's this star trek episode
there's a lot of
doctor who star trek miscellaneous
episodes and then galaxy quest which is
a parody of star trek
definitely use time travel in a similar
kind of way where they just kind of
rewind it back and then and then fix
something the omega 13
activate the omega 13. awesome which i
think was
the influence for the first j.j abrams
star trek movie opening
with chris hemsworth where he says we're
executing general order 13. evacuate the
ship immediately that 13
is influenced by galaxy questions galaxy
quest full circle that was such a cool
thing
and the last one on our list here is the
movie frequency jim caviezel
dennis quaid father and son a magic
radio allows them to speak to each other
across
decades to help his firefighter father
prevent his death but ends up
accidentally allowing a murderer
to kill his mom and then they fight the
same guy past and present and has my
favorite time travel plot hole hector
movie where once the timeline gets
revised in the past dennis quaid beats
the bad guy
uh in the future disgrace shows up
randomly gray hair with a shotgun and
blows him away
implying that in the revised timeline
dance squad must have been sitting alone
in his bedroom
with a shotgun waiting for the right
moment for his son to almost die
and then showed up and blew him away for
years i've been waiting
that was an awesome movie when i saw it
as a kid i really enjoyed i haven't seen
it in years but i remember thinking it
was the coolest
father-son adventure movie it's great uh
it's got a great
garth brooks title song to it on a
prayer oh
i'm there i kind of sing it like creed
that's not garth brooks that's not
garth brooks or chris gaines i
i don't know do we ever really know
that's kind of like the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
if the box is open it's garth brooks if
it's closed it's chris gaines correct
correct right
yeah quick quick question where does the
time travel element for men in black
three
fall into what would you is that also a
time travel because i only bring it up
because
men in black three features pretty
conventional time travel
where agent jay goes back in time and
eventually you learned that he's in his
own past and there's a younger version
of himself there
but then at the end of the movie when he
was fighting jermaine clements alien
character
bad guy he he goes forward will smith
goes forward gets shot a couple times in
the shoulder and then rewinds time a few
seconds
and instead of there being a duplicate
will smith there which would have been
the established rules of that time
travel right movie
there's just no other will smith there
and then he's able to know what moves
the bad guy's going to do dodges them
and then defeats a bad guy
[Music]
damn he ain't gonna be in rush hour
three where would that fall under
it's it's a hybrid right it's a hybrid
between the classic version and then
another version we'll talk about later
where it almost feels like unstuck mind
right like a kind of back
and so um i think in general if the
rules are not well defined it probably
leads to more towards
it in the same way that austin powers
spy you shagged me that's totally uh a
good story as well why not use your
knowledge of the future to play the
stock market
we could make trillions why make
trillions when we could make
billions it goes back in time and his
teeth are not fixed it's like that
doesn't make any sense doesn't make any
sense
so um is this realistic no not at all
this type is just fantasy it's based on
wish fulfillment themes if i could just
change my past if i could go to the
future
it's the share song that we should have
heard these stories really as i said
they're all based on like
one timeline each of them are set in one
timeline that goes back and forth on
honestly hector i regret wasting all of
our time on it so i'm gonna
send this version of me back in time
just to erase it from this episode
okay
all right moving on to our next type
type two of time travel
is what we call the branch reality time
travel
this is kind of um an advancement it's
when the screenwriters start to realize
oh we have to apply some logic we really
want to play with this genre
so in this version when you make changes
to past they don't rewrite history they
split
the timeline into an alternate branch
reality and that original timeline is
not changed or erased by this action
it's just like a it's a more disciplined
approach than
yeah we were talking about earlier back
to the future part two changes the rules
talk about that eric
so uh doc brown makes that amazing i
think
all of our hearts lept when he got out
that blackboard and drew the 1985
b we're like yes yes yes yes uh and
talked about how
actually history isn't set on one
timeline in this case the sports almanac
being given to young biff
to become basically donald trump third
time's a charm
right that's insane how history just
kind of became
the darkest timeline from back to the
future but it doesn't change the fact
that 1985 a
still exists on the space time continuum
they just have to get back to it
so actually branch realities i think my
favorite example of the branch reality
time travel in recent years has got to
be avengers end game
i feel that although there's a lot of
confusion from audiences
to me it's pretty clear sort of what
they're describing for the most part
and we get visual explanations we get
mark ruffalo's bruce banner explaining
it to us twice
it's given us endless theories and
possibilities but
this is something that i think is is
pretty well understood
when they're traveling to 2012 when
they're traveling to 2014 it is an
alternate reality and those actions are
affecting a different reality
we're going to get a different loki
because loki died the loki show is going
right that 2012 loki who disappeared
yeah and same for
for captain america at the end of the
movie it's so weird that the
screenwriters of endgame claim that cap
lived within that timeline
and became an old man just in the ice in
the background when they were so
clear that it's supposed to create a
branch reality i
i listen i think it's because those
writers also worked on the agent carter
tv show they love piggy carter yeah
that's where we got the jarvis cameo how
could you not love hayley atwell and i
feel that they strongly felt like look
we established peggy carter we
established steve rogers because they
wrote the first captain america movie
and every subsequent cat movie
they really wanted those two versions of
those two characters to end up together
of course we all would guys
but that's not how reality works
definitely not it's funny that like
scott lang says
so back to the future is a bunch of
[ __ ] which like every nerd of time
travel in the audience is like
no it's not back to the future part two
clearly covered this form of logic it's
like he only watched a first back to the
future and didn't realize
that there's a second one that already
made sense it would make sense scott
lang seems like
he's maybe not all the way up to uh pop
culture references basically any movie
that deals
with time travel die hard no that's not
one and maybe that was like a meta joke
by the filmmakers there they're like no
back to the future part two is exactly
what we are doing
they they clearly do love back to the
future but i also think it was fun to
actually see a movie
reference how the first back to the
future doesn't really make any logical
sense but who cares we love you
and there's been a whole bunch of other
examples of this so a wrinkle in time
madeleine l'engle it's it's all based on
like
branch theory multiple universes ages of
shield season seven we won't go too deep
into it in case you haven't seen it yet
but that it deals with that as well it
actually kind of clarifies a lot from in
game
um and then in the comics the dc
multiverse from the flashpoint paradox
and then the marvel multiverse with
characters like hang the conqueror
they deal with like branch theory as
well and then the the rick and morty
episode from this pasty is one of my
favorite episodes of the show the vat of
acid episode
began by thinking it's a different type
of time travel we're going to talk about
later this episode but then
was revealed to be like the rules of
rick and morty it's multiverse so every
time morty was resetting he was actually
going into
a new timeline and then you mentioned
the star trek one so star trek
in 2009 reboot the franchise using time
travel and they split
reality from the prime timeline that's
one that had william shatner kirk
leonard nimoy spock
nimoy spock showed up in this movie but
they went through a time portal
along with nero and then they split onto
a new timeline called the kelvin
timeline and that's what all the jj
abrams movies are set on which with
chris pine uh zachary quinto but that
prime timeline is not erased
oh i'm gonna blow your mind even further
i'm gonna blow it even further do it do
it do it
blow your mind for years star trek fans
have been arguing about that first
2009 star trek film at the jj abrams
kelvin timeline saying
it doesn't make any sense if it was only
nero that went back in time
and affected everything right from james
t kirk's birth
and beyond that why does he look
different than william shatner why does
he have different color eyes why does
the bridge to the ship the enterprise
look different why is it
bigger why is all these little cosmetic
differences that would not have had
anything to do with
nero and the answer is because in star
trek for the voyage
home if we're to believe the branch
reality timeline theory to be correct
in star trek iv the voyage home the crew
of the enterprise with the original
william shatner leonard nimoy
kirk and spock going back in time there
they
start to branch a reality because scotty
creates invisible aluminum or whatever
that
that material is yeah yeah they're
already like advancing science further
than it should have been in the 80s
uh they also kidnap a whale doctor and
bring her to their
future presence so in my theory
the kelvin timeline is actually just
further along in that original branch
reality
that the original crew already did so
where science and technology might have
been a little bit more advanced because
of what they did in the 1980s in san
francisco
you get a starfleet that looks a little
sleeker you get a ship that's a little
bit bigger
yeah quit it with your constantly poking
holes and stuff just enjoy star trek
consider it a sequel to star trek for
the voyage home
you're welcome internet you fixed it
there's a there's a vent at the top that
sucked up my hat that's my favorite
simpsons gag
[Laughter]
so uh is this realistic hector kinda so
the endgame writers
consulted with quantum physicists
stepped into the quantum leap
accelerator
and they talk about the many worlds
theory this is a real thing in quantum
mechanics but quantum mechanics itself
is not proven to be real yet
um but they hypothesize that this is how
time travel would theoretically work
uh however there are even more recent
breakthroughs that we will come back to
this episode
so uh this is kind of like the the
adolescence to the kids
childhood since it's not exactly
accurate i'm gonna send branch timeline
eric uh back to fix whatever the other
eric did good luck
all right hector we move on to type
three of our time travel plots this one
is called time dilation time dilation
what's that
so time dilation is when characters
travel through like trippy space time
and they uh they experience time moving
more slowly
than characters back on earth do so this
is the type of time travel you see in
planet of the apes
in ender's game that great movie fly to
the navigator
that i watched as a kid um and then uh
speaking of christopher nolan it says we
can interstellar
so throughout the plot of interstellar
that's mcconaughey's big things like i
gotta get back home before my daughter
grows older than me and he's you know
there's time dilation
based off gravity because time they say
is a variable
not a constant that's affected by the
different gravity close to a black hole
and a lot of
astrophysicists say this is possible you
know they leave that poor guy up on
the main ship for decades by himself why
that guy didn't off himself i don't
understand
also to just go back to that first one
you mentioned i remember the first time
i saw a planet of the apes what a twist
what twist one the best tweet the end of
that movie one of the greatest all-time
movie twists to be able to say nope your
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years
on earth's future that you only
experience because of time dilation
that's exactly that's right
plus avengers end game how else can we
explain paul rudd's slow
aging he was in the quantum realm for
for what was five years but to him was
only five minutes but
eric how did janet van dyne also age
normally
i'm gonna link you to this video
but uh basically janet didn't go through
time not everyone who goes in the
quantum realm travels through time only
people go with
into time vortexes within the quantum
realm go through time so when scott did
that before end game changed the rules i
think a total of three times with its
own movie time scott was
time dilated there so he experienced
five hours the rest of the world
experienced five years and is this
realistic actually yes
incredibly so i'm shocked because
characters are not moving backwards in
time this version only applies to moving
forward in time and it applies
einstein's theory of relativity and i
would say on our list it is the second
most realistic type
so we're making progress going back in
time a lot of physicists are like
we don't really have a good way to do
that yet but moving forward in time
theoretically possible so we're going to
send time dilation eric
back actually you know what it turns out
he's already been in space this whole
time and he's going to go back and
see if the other time eric's um can
figure it out he's gonna go back and
help but
okay okay hector now we're gonna move on
to a very confusing
maybe the most confusing form of time
travel but it shows up so often
it is called type 4 this always happened
time travel so and this always happened
this is a time that's set on a
predestined fixed
loop in which the very act of time
travel itself
sets the events of the story into motion
revealed later in the story the examples
of this
are terminator of course one of the most
famous time travel fiction stories
kyle reese was sent back to protect
sarah connor by future general john
connor
but kyrie's conceives that john connor
with sarah
basically justifying his own timeline
and and we see this again
in t2 miles dyson explains how the
leftover t800 ship from the first movie
is what made cyberdyne's advancements
possible so without the time travel we
wouldn't have had all this crazy skynet
[ __ ] that we have to worry about
plus the end of those terminator movies
at least terminator one and two
and then you can look at like terminator
3 being different terminator salvation
being a different
sort of version of time travel
terminator dark fate each of those
movies i just mentioned have an
ending where they're able to still
prevent the future or delay it in some
way
so those are almost kind of branching
realities as well right the
the world where the terminators came
from in parts one and two
was effectively delayed and transformed
into something else when you watch
terminator dark fate
and then the end of that movie spoiler
alert they saved the day again so
there's a bunch of different stuff going
on
i like terminator it's cool cool
terminator's nuts
um now the silliest example of it i
think is harry potter and the prisoner
of azkaban
weird [ __ ] starts to happen that's
unexplained and then we find out that
the
person who cast the patronus in earlier
to save them
was a future version of himself it's a
fixed loop i'm not gonna lie when i say
this is maybe my most favorite example
of time travel in a movie
ever because i find it to be so airtight
that i'm just like
that's that's the way to do it i love
that stuff and then harry potter
broke this process by dewey and harry
potter and their cursed child spoiler
warning does deal with time turners
really i didn't know that well that's
such
a little spoiler yeah um you don't need
to watch it it's not canon in my mind
and it shouldn't be canon in anyone's
minds
and that's the least offensive thing
that play does
almost ruined so many things in my life
i hate harry potter and the girls child
actually maybe that's what i'll do for
the third question that we do later in
this episode
yeah also famously in game of thrones
season six this is actually the first
video i hosted for new rockstars
the hold the door episode bran projects
his mind into hodor's body back in the
past
hodor was a totally normal kid but bran
so fried his brain
to link with his present version of
himself so he's holding
our hodor that's why hodor says hodor
wow 12 monkeys is another example so
in 12 monkeys bruce willis fails to
prevent a past disease outbreak and dies
in a way that fulfills his childhood
memories of seeing
his future self dying interstellar
there's another version of time travel
and interstellar
really the big reveal at the end uh so
murph's bookcase
ghost was future matthew mcconaughey
using gravitational forces
to communicate with her cool and
emotional
cool and emotional there's that weird
moment where anne hathaway looks over
and sees this weird swirling cloud
and that's revealed later to be
mcconaughey trying to reach out to her
in the past
okay it's a great movie just got some
weird rules going on one of my favorite
examples of this form of time travel is
the rom-com
kate and leopold yes starring hugh
jackman uh sabretooth peter sarsgaard
and meg ryan
directed by james mangle who directed
logan and
uh ford vs ferrari and you can tell he's
just like i'm not gonna do a
rom-com i'm gonna make it crazy and it's
one of these
um this always happens stories because
at the end of the movie peter sarsgaard
realizes that meg and hugh belong
together because his past visits to the
past in the opening scene
showed her already there he said your
future is in the past
oh crazy twist when i saw that
as a kid um and then the not that great
movie the butterfly effect ashton
kutcher
uses his journals in the future and then
that's what caused his childhood
blackouts that he
grew up having i i would say this might
lean more towards the type one
kid or a type .05 punk
that's probably what that is after
you've got your punk time travel
what is that why is that a problem and
then uh we won't talk about the movie
pre-destination it's one of the most
complicated time travel stories but
basically
they try to address the grandfather
paradox by making
ethan hawk like kind of his own ancestor
and then his own killer and his own
lover there's like a sex change
oh my god i got to watch this movie it's
a crazy movie
but basically it's called predestination
because it's a this always happens story
wow real quick uh rick and morty episode
five that was the snake episode of
season four
um that was revealed to be a terminator
type plot actually they did a little
easter egg and the ship was already
there early in the episode where they
were watching
their their past selves go through so
they can close the loop and then the
movie looper
which is one of my favorite time travel
stories ryan johnson
like 12 monkeys bruce willis isn't it
goes on a mission in the past
but it's that mission that causes his
target kid to grow up
evil to one day kill his wife so the act
of time travel is what caused that dark
fate joseph gordon-levitt sees this
close the loop in the coolest possible
way it's great because this one actually
gives the hero free will
so i like that yeah it also has it also
has that time travel logic of like
somebody in the past is getting tortured
and getting like their fingers and toes
yeah yeah yeah yeah in the present
they're just all of a sudden
disappearing
so i don't know what kind of time travel
logic that is either but
that was one of the reasons i could not
fully get into looper
even though it's a fantastic movie and
it's so well made but i was like what's
happening what's going on here how does
this
work yeah looper deals with like new
memories that characters have and they
just
like there's a great scene where it
leans more into [ __ ] it where
uh bruce willis is just like i wanna
talk about time travel [ __ ]
because if we start talking about it
then we're gonna be here all day talking
about it making diagrams with straws
okay movie let's get moving that's great
so is this realistic
i would say depends on who you pray to
um because these stories are i would say
are sometimes not even time travel
stories to begin with
because that reveal is really kind of
used as i'll call it i'll call it cheap
i think it's a cheap cathartic reveal
it's a bit tropy at this point it's rare
that it is such a payoff
and again i use prisoner of azkaban as a
great example where i think it was
really well done in that movie same sort
of thing with the book that's a good
payoff and it's like
yeah it's it's it's rare that that
reveal feels like that like
oh the whole time the whole time it's
usually more like
okay all right yeah yeah at this point
it's been done
and honestly it poses some problematic
implications about the lack of free will
like
characters are interesting because they
have free will they can make choices and
if it's suddenly revealed at the end of
the movie that everything they did was
pre-ordained
it kind of like well i hope you don't
have a sequel in mind
because now it's like a bible story you
know rather than are they scientifically
accurate they're more theologically
accurate so um you know if if if you
want some spirituality out of your
stories which you know harry potter is a
pretty spiritual story
great great cool that's why a lot of
people love these but here's what we're
going to do we're going to send
this always happened eric he's going to
pray his way back to the past and he's
going to
have already been there the whole time
good
because i'm not trying to go to hell
eric okay i'm not watching harry potter
that stuff's
devil i'm not trying to go ahead no
halloween no harry potter that's it
no pokemon no harry potter those are
both banned at school
no scarlet witch i looked into it she's
witch
that reminds me of a i forget where i
heard this story eric and you could cut
this out of the episode if you want
but years ago i heard this on a podcast
somewhere i can't remember where but
somebody was describing
when they went to go see the first
spider-man movie in 2002
they were in like middle school or high
school or something before the movie
started this
like pastor of like a church youth group
that was there got up in front of the
screen and said
hey i just want to let everybody know
before we watch this movie the only one
who could climb up walls and shoot webs
would be the lord jesus christ
like the audience booed this person like
get out of here
so the inside joke between me and my
buddy is whenever we see something
amazing in a movie
we always go the only one
who could travel through time and
collect infinity stones
is the lord jesus christ amen that's the
joke
and i think it's very funny man i wish i
was in the theater
my favorite stories are the stories of
like weird [ __ ] people do in movie
theaters
it's always fun it's so great i don't
know how that would have that would have
changed my
relationship with the movie spider-man
forever every time i watch it i would
have thought of that guy
all right so now we're on to type 5
which you might argue this isn't a type
of time travel but we have to address it
because it's actually very important in
the history of time travel fiction
seeing the future time travel this is
where characters see a
vision of the future that allows them to
try to change their current course
to avert that faded history or i guess
in some cases steer directly into that
history right
classically in greek mythology or greek
drama there's oedipus rex he gets the
the premonition from teresius and then
he ends up actually doing exactly that
killing
his father mary and his mother and then
charles dickens explored it with the
christmas carol
scrooge was shown a future where a tiny
tim died
so he's able to course correct and and
not be such a dick
minority report it's a very cool movie
based on a philip k dick
uh story and then spielberg made the
movie where the precogs kinda are able
to say who's about to die
and then by trying to avoid that fate
tom cruise actually
goes into an exact version of it yeah
reminds me another couple examples a
rival has a version of this yes
right where amy adams but you the big
reveal by the end of that movie is that
what we thought were her memories of the
past and a child that she lost
was her seeing into the future because
of her interacting with these aliens
yes that it was going to be a child that
she hadn't had yet and she still decides
to go through with
having a child even though it ends in
tragedy
and her and jeremy renner like end up
like losing their kid at some point but
she goes through with it anyway
because it's the love of a child another
great example too probably i would say a
movie is as good as a rival
next starring nicholas cage he can also
see the future
that one's crazy i love it yeah it's
insane because at the end of the movie
the big reveal is that about half of the
movie didn't happen and that he's
sitting in a hotel room and he's like i
saw it all i'm not going to do that and
then that's the end of the movie
that's bonkers that that happens yeah
there's also a nick cage movie called
knowing
where he sees like there's a character
who's able to predict the future
yeah i think so knowing dealt with like
numbers and numerology yeah
yeah right the big twist in that was
that like he was able to predict
when like tragedies would happen like
plane crashes and stuff there's like 9
11 was on there how many people die
and then that ended with aliens coming
to wipe out the planet except for a
select number of humans including
nicholas cage and his
son nicholas cage doesn't make it his
son makes sense
burns that movie's insane that's so
crazy
um i'm so glad he brought up a rival a
rival's such an a profound film
yeah that everyone needs to see it's a
version of like seeing the future but
it's also kind of like a weird um
this always happened type story it's
also kind of a weird um
unstuck mind one that we'll get to in a
bit where the character is kind of like
consciousness is projecting forward in
time the best time travel stories are
hybrids i think
i just want everyone to know before we
watch a rival the only one
who could see their unborn child in the
future
and be able to translate languages with
aliens
is our lord and savior jesus christ amen
now rick and morty season 4 also dealt
with this with the death crystals and
the
season 4 premiere where morty could see
his future death and then kind of steer
toward that or some other fate
ooh i know we mentioned this before with
star trek but speaking of crystals
in the recent series star trek discovery
in season two
they have a classic character
christopher pike captain pike who uh
bruce greenwood played in the j.j abrams
kelvin timeline is played by anson mount
in the new
series at one point his character is
able to see his own future
and how he ends up in a horrible fate
that goes back to the 1960s original
star trek show
and it gives a new meaning to the
character because the character decides
to still forge forward
and be a starfleet captain knowing what
his ultimate fate's going to be
which just completely added a whole
nother side to the character so
if anybody watching right now hasn't
seen star trek discovery pretty cool
stuff in there
that adds some pretty cool stuff to star
trek this message was brought to you by
cbs this kind of shows up a lot
characters just kind of having a dream
of the future so bat maybe superman
there was a whole like nightmare
sequence and then flash shows up he's
like am i too soon
and we never really got to saw maybe the
snyder cut will go into that we'll see
possibly and and it's weird because it
was still sort of a dream also so it was
so does that count
as as seeing the future does that count
as the consciousness
thing like like it's weird the dream was
a dream it looks like but then flash
showing up
did happen because it was after the
dream and there were still papers
floating down
and it seemed like out of another dream
you know what i hope
we just learned some cool stuff about
this flash movie it looks like they're
gonna be doing flashpoint
and they're bringing in affleck they're
bringing in keaton like
this could be the movie that fixes
everything that people didn't like about
the dc eu
and ends that version of history and
that's just that but including
every other dc movie franchise where's
val kilmer let's get george clooney
back in the suit let's get all the
batman's let's get kevin conroy in that
robotronica
thing he was wearing in the cw show
let's go for it
yeah i i'm so excited for that movie and
then yeah you're also saying avengers
infinity war doctor strange had the
vision of the future and then that
affected like how they did everything
is this realistic well a lot of people
don't call this time travel
you know characters aren't traveling
through time they're just kind of like
seeing things but they are
altering timelines and i would say this
is somewhat realistic
because self-fulfilling prophecies are a
real thing in human nature
people get fearful of what they might
become and then become that thing
so i don't know but it's still not
physically scientifically accurate
i'm going to send c in the future eric
and i hope he doesn't
things up too bad
all right we're moving on to type six
this is the time loop
groundhog day type of time travel you
guys know this one this is where
characters are
stuck reliving a day over and over again
and they reset back to a respawn point
where whenever they die or fall asleep
become incapacitated
famously groundhog day is the one
everyone thinks of but also movies like
uh tom cruises
edge of tomorrow really great movie the
doctor strange final battle with
dormammu the bargain that was a
groundhog day time loop
the netflix show russian doll deals with
this the recent movie
palm springs deals with this uh happy
death day both
but the second movie deals with like
multiverse the second the sequel that's
crazy
and then yeah the rick and morty episode
we talked about wonderful fiction
i i would debate that this might not be
time travel per se
is it realistic is it realistic could
somebody actually get stuck in a time
loop
i've been worrying about this since i
saw groundhog day as a kid eric
i mean we're kind of experiencing that
now yeah right it's realistic
in that sense every day is the same
despite all the quantum
mechanics that they dig into in palm
springs i don't think
it's realistic so we're gonna send um
groundhog day eric and he's the scariest
because if you think about if you relive
a day over and over you basically become
an immortal you become a god
i am a god you dull creature and i will
not be bullied by that
careful other eric's this one's going to
be a killer
congratulations you played yourself all
right hector
this type uh type 7 is my favorite type
of time travel it is called the unstuck
mind this is consciousness displacement
this is where characters
minds transport back to a time when
their bodies
were a different age so their bodies
don't travel their minds do
this is um kurt vonnegut slaughterhouse
five is one of the first ones that
really dug into this
though billy pilgrim the protagonist in
that does not have free will he's just
kind of a
passive observer to his timeline but the
one you guys might know of is x-men
day's the future past
right so wolverine's mind thanks to
kitty pride it gets blown back to his
younger self back decades before so they
can
change the timeline but don't worry he's
still ripped as hell oh yeah even more
ripped if it's
even more ripped than the first x-men
movie
the 70s is crazy now the series lost if
you watch that there was
the character desmond his uh he became
unstuck in time his mind and there's
that amazing episode the constant where
past and future versions of him he has
like
conversations with penny and she is his
constant and she tries to like
lock it i'm tearing up if not the best
episodes
of that series and one of the best
examples of what we're talking about i
feel like
people still remember that moment in the
show and i feel like it was also a real
kind of turning point within the show i
mean the show had already explored
sci-fi stuff before then yeah but that
was really when it was like we're going
for it we're going for it
so hang on they did they made the island
itself unstuck in time in later seasons
yes they
they tried to stay true to it it kind of
worked not the people on the island
the people who came back were not
unstuck in time i think right was that
how that worked i think i need to
rewatch that show i think so yeah i just
remember there being a donkey wheel i
also need to re-watch the show it's one
of my favorites and it's always
difficult talking about the show because
i feel like if somebody hasn't seen the
show
it's the worst way to get into the show
is to hear somebody talking yeah
just watch the first episode give it a
shot good point
and i also have to say it's the first
movie script i wrote dealt with
consciousness displacement time travel
um it'll never get made but um i'm proud
of what i did
oh exactly how not to make a movie make
a college comedy that deals with crazy
special effects and time travel wait
that's happy death day
[ __ ] i should make this movie so is this
form realistic
well the human mind actor the human mind
does find itself you know drifting
nostalgically into the past
or sometimes hopefully idealistically
into the future one could argue this
form of time travel
is the most grounded in human nature
because we're not always present
but it's not necessarily grounded in
science i would say as youtubers hector
and i drift all the time our
consciousness back in old videos
whenever we watch ourselves
uh wishing we did things differently
differently
hi what where am i tomorrow and i'd be a
great oh my god
oh wow the 2016 election hasn't happened
yet
look how hopeful i look oh wow i'm also
hopeful that
the game of thrones final seasons might
actually play out in a way that's
satisfying
get out now eric get out
oh my god this um i'm starting to lose
it so i'm just gonna like mentally
project unstuck mind eric back to the
top of the episode to prevent this from
happening
yeah maybe in another life brother see
you in another life brother
all right hector we have arrived at type
8 our final type we are calling this the
unstuck body time travel
so this one is very interesting this is
uh where characters bodies experience
changes to their physical properties
detaching them from their environment
and inverting those bodies within the
system they're in oh
interesting what's really interesting
about about this too is the the hats
you're wearing
just keep getting smaller getting
smaller it's classic comedic heightening
the smaller the hat the bigger the last
so this is kind of like where we see
time
reversal so in doctor strange in the
hong kong battle
there was a really cool thing that we
hadn't seen a whole lot in movies where
time is moving in reverse
while characters are moving forward and
using that reversing time for strategic
advantage
so like he's able to use a reassembling
building to
trap one of the zealots and i thought
that's so cool and i feel like
christopher nolan saw that he's like i
could make that into a whole movie
yeah because that's basically what tenet
is avengers in game also taps into this
very briefly just for a joke but it's
where they're experimenting and they
move time through scott lang
and they re-age his body they
accidentally discover immortality if you
think about it
okay let's talk about tenet i we made a
whole other big question episode dealing
with the
uh the laws of thermodynamics and
entropy if you
watch the movie by the time you're
seeing this episode you probably know a
bit more
but go watch that episode and we'll be
making more and more videos about tennis
but basically it deals with the concept
of maxwell's
demon that uh supposes that
a door could be open between systems
that allows
kind of like cosmic divine force to
predict
where particles will go what what kind
of quantum trajectory they have
so you're able to control a system and
basically control something like entropy
which basically is the natural
disability stabilization of the universe
so if you're able to reverse that
you can invert one thing within a system
whether it's a bullet
or a body or a car or a boat you can
invert the entropy of that and move in a
different
vector an opposite vector i don't know
if i fully understood what i just said
yeah you blacked out there for a second
but you look good
but the the key to this type is that
you're only focusing the inverted time
on
one body within a system best example of
this and everyone needs to go watch this
movie it's called primer
to date it is the most thoughtful time
travel film ever made
to a fault because it's um not
necessarily the best acted film
what no it's a very small budget it's
amazing that they accomplished what they
accomplished
so there are all kinds of infographics
you can see on how primer works but
basically engineers develop a way to
enter a box they get
primed over several hours and then they
travel back in time over the course of
that
so that they can meddle with the past
meanwhile their old version themselves
has to go hide in a hotel room so they
don't interfere with themselves
but they can't ever go back to before
that box was first turned on
that's the key so they can never go back
beyond that first origin point
but then they create loops within loops
uh there's other fail-safe boxes
uh there's boxes within boxes but it's
one of the most fascinating and
mathematically accurate versions of time
travel that works the same way of the
unstuck body
is this version of time travel the most
realistic turns out
yes so christopher nolan's tenant primer
this is
the most based on what quantum mechanics
experts are experimenting on
last year mathematicians used an ibm
quantum computer similar to what i guess
tony stark had an endgame they simulated
a way to undo the aging
of a single elementary particle by
one millionth of a second it was all
simulated they didn't actually do this
but they showed
that if they could control all the
variables in nature
they could theoretically stop the agent
of something and reverse
the aging this is all based on quantum
mechanics the uncertainty principle
that basically says that einstein must
be wrong for this to be true oh
hell no it's very scary but they did
acknowledge at the end of the experiment
that real world nature is just too
complex too chaotic that you can never
control the variables like that but
christopher nolan thinks he can whoa
that's so cool yeah
this is our most scientifically accurate
version of time travel with tenet
we are now entering a new age of time
travel fiction that's the most grounded
yet in real world physics it allows us
to see what true
inverted entropy or quantum mechanics
would look like applied to the real
world
unstuck bodies uh and since this is the
most realistic version of time travel
we've found it
i'm gonna reverse unstuck body eric back
to the top to just make sure no one else
picks anything up
all right uh we're gonna quickly thank
some uh people helped us make this
episode starting with our friends at
bespoke post
as we all settled to this new normal
version of summer bespoke post is here
with customized
boxes of awesome for you guys guaranteed
to
upgrade your life bespoke post only
sends guys the best stuff every month no
matter what you're into boxing of
awesome has you covered
from style and grooming goods to bar
wear cooking tools outdoor gear box of
awesome has carefully built collections
for every part of your life one of their
current boxes looks super cool
is their turbo box from drive coffee
it's all these different coffees that
are like automotive themed and they come
in containers that look like oil and gas
cans
cute that's cool yeah there's also the
forge
box that comes with a really cool
looking damascus steel pocket knife
it's perfect for whittling on the porch
like ron swanson or
shaking at the squirrels that keeps
stealing your birdseed
hey come on now to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
can skip
a month or cancel anytime each box only
costs 45 bucks but it has over
70 worth of gear inside nice get a 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com and enter
the code
big question at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code big question
for 20 off your first box and real quick
we want to also thank our friends at
doordash for sponsoring this episode you
can continue to support restaurants and
your communities safely by using
doordash
doordash is the app that brings you food
you're craving right now
right to your door ordering is easy you
just open the doordash app
choose what you want to eat and your
food will be left safely outside your
door with the new
contact list delivery drop-off setting
with over 300 000 partners in the us
puerto rico canada australia you can
support your local go-to's
or choose from your favorite national
restaurants like chipotle
wendy's womb or cheesecake factory no no
no no no no no no no no
no and shout out to cheesecake factory
for their good i have a chocolate
cheesecake which i had for my birthday
this year which i can now get safely
delivered right to my door
by doordash many of your favorite local
restaurants are still open for delivery
just open the door dash app select your
favorite local restaurant and your food
will be left at your door doordash
deliveries are now contact lists to keep
communities we operate and
safe right now our listeners can get
five dollars off and zero delivery fees
on their first order of fifteen dollars
or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code big question
that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app in the
app store
and enter the code big question don't
forget that's code big question for five
dollars off your first order with
doordash we're now going to move on to
some bite-sized questions that hector is
going to answer for us you ready hector
i'm ready all right so our friend
unventalone on discord asks
did captain america create a domino
effect when telling his past self that
bucky was alive and also whispering hail
hydra
to sit well in the elevator i think yes
because my theory is that the way that
time travel was explained to the
audience in avengers end game
even with the visual representation from
the ancient one with that cool little
line that travels through the movie
i think this is the major hang up in
explaining the time travel is the visual
representation because if you listen to
the words that bruce banner and the
ancient one are saying
she's talking about how every time you
take away one of these stones it's going
to create a new branching reality
and your reality bruce banner with the
stones may be fine
but this one is going to be left
unguarded and then bruce says i don't
think the science supports that if we go
back
and bring the stones back to that
reality he says
in that reality it's like the stones
never left
is what he said is what he described so
the visual then
erases that complete and i think that's
where people get tripped up where they
go oh that means that if you put the
stone back the
alternate reality gets erased completely
not necessarily
because we're gonna get a loki show it's
that loki that disappeared that 2012
avengers you know fight sequence where
the the present avengers went back into
the past of 2012
and captain america was messing with the
hydra soldiers and messing with his past
self and having to fight america's ass
he is going to set things up in that
reality when he tells himself bucky's
alive
in 2012 two years before he finds out in
2014 in captain america in the winter
soldier
i think that steve is going to go
investigate it and when he says hell
hydra
to jasper sitwell i think that that
sitwell is going to tell
that robert redford and i think that
they're going to kick things off a
little bit sooner they're going to go
what
is steve does he know about us or is he
in on it and that's going to
that that means that that jasper sit
well the next time he sees steve rogers
is gonna go
he'll hydra and steve's gonna go what
did you say and that's gonna start
things a little bit different
but it's fine because it's all an
alternate reality we're gonna get the
multiverse of madness and
doctor strange two i think we're gonna
see that explored we got
it teased in spider-man far from home
but that was a scam that wasn't real
that wasn't real jake gyllenhaal was
from our reality not some other reality
to answer the question i do think
that he is creating a domino effect and
if we never see it
because chris evans may be done i feel
like that's the perfect opportunity
to do something in animated form or for
marvel to put out a comic
that's like oh yeah yeah mcu tie-in it's
like by the way here's what happens in
this reality i
love that i would love that too yeah
whether an episode of what if or
something or yeah italian comic that'd
be amazing
all right next question civilian from
our discord asks how was mantis able to
sleep a celestial-like ego but couldn't
keep
thanos in a trance that long in infinity
war i would love to get your take on
this erica have a couple of ideas but
the main one i was thinking about was
that
mantis was very used to putting ego to
sleep
she had been kind of growing up and
being raised by him and it was a very
weird and interesting relationship but
he was keeping her there for the purpose
of her
using her powers on him whereas this is
the first time she even laid hands on
thanos you know what i mean this is a
competition right yeah being so that's
my take is that mantis was just more
experienced and more familiar with
ego and ego's insanely complex
brain patterns and different things that
make ego ego whereas thanos is an
entirely new beast
eric do you have any other ideas
thoughts or theories yeah some have said
um maybe like ego lets mantis do it to
her whereas thanos was fighting her off
but like mantis tries to do that later
with ego when he
doesn't want her to do it but yeah what
you say makes a lot of sense i also i
mean
let's acknowledge the power levels are
always kind of out of whack
theoretically as a celestial ego should
be more powerful but i think ego
used to be more powerful his like origin
point has a brain floating through space
he actually had a light there's a theory
that he
the the skull that nowhere was might
have had ego's brain
and so he was decapitated by by null
with the necro
sword cool do you think we're gonna get
null in the mcu like
you're talking about the venom right
it's more tied to uh
yeah to venom and carnage it's a
symbiote god i don't know i feel like
that's a sony property
disney's gonna have to buy sony before
they could do that but they can hint at
it they could totally hint at it but
thanos had four infinity stones when he
was shaking her off and i think that's a
big thing the mad titan with four
infinity stones is more powerful than
ego is all right one uh question more
for you
brooke asks would professor x be able to
cause an event similar to the snap using
cerebro
because in x2 we see him almost wipe out
all the humans could he do this to half
of all life in the universe
well here's the other thing that i love
to talk about that's so awesome about
marvel and dc comic book universes and a
lot of fictional universes like
i'm a big trekkie and i'm into star trek
star trek has only ever dealt with
the galaxy that's it and so has star
wars because a galaxy is already so
unfathomably huge
that to then go beyond that and go no no
not just our galaxy but
every galaxy in the universe that's what
the green lantern corps
covers yeah that's what the guardians of
the galaxy may cover the galaxy but they
also go to different parts of the
universe the marvel universe is much
bigger than that
it's insane so when you say can could
cerebral really kill half of all life in
the universe my
instantaneous response is no way jose
absolutely no way
could a machine built by a person now
that person is a mutant sure
but could a machine built by a human
being do what the
primordial stones of the building blocks
of the universe
do when they're put together i go
immediately no but
it is fun to think about it it's fun to
speculate and it's especially fun
because
the mcu is set up to be that larger
universal storytelling
the x-men movies that we've gotten in
fox's x-men film series
have really only been relegated to earth
except for like
x-men dark phoenix which had the uh
jessica chastain alien come down
and it's like when you bring in the
phoenix forest i feel like those films
have been
focusing on their own thing but also in
a way limited because they are not able
to just be like
let's bring in you know galactus and
let's bring in the silver surface let's
bring in all these different elements to
do let's bring in thanos let's bring in
the infinity gauntlet which is what
makes marvel great is the opportunity
that these people could show up
absolutely yes when i think about this
you know fun potential story lines are
like look black panther in like the
nation of wakanda eventually go to space
like that's
crazy that's crazy bonker stuff and the
x-men
are flipping around on space all the
time scott summer's dad has been in
space
he's the leader of the star jammers like
that's stuff we haven't gotten in movies
yet
if and when we see the x-men in the
marvel cinematic universe maybe
something like that could be more of a
possibility maybe that charles xavier
could be building cerebro with like cree
or scroll tech
i don't know that could be cool you
never know what we could get with um
potential story threads
in in that regard so in the world of x2
probably not
but beyond in the future theoretically
yeah yeah yeah all right we have time
for one more bunch of scraps
questions what we call it here hector
keeping on the theme of
time travel our question if you could
time travel to interact with your
younger self
using any of the eight forms we talked
about well not all bees and all of them
could do that
what specific piece of advice would you
give or what decision would you make
differently
oh boy i can't think of any big major
bad decisions
i think the main thing i would say would
be like hey try to move to los
angeles from san diego way sooner
because you're really just wasting some
time in san diego like get up there
maybe you could have had aziz ansari's
career on parks and recreation if you
had head up to la
earlier started doing improv earlier you
know who knows what could have happened
eric you know about this being in the in
the improv comedy in los angeles the
community
there's lots of stories of like yeah
there's a group of folks who just we're
kind of here at
right place right time right place right
time they're all in movies now and it's
like oh
really i missed that i missed it okay
cool
yeah i mean like and you hear about this
especially in new york like there was a
period in the early 2000s in new york
where you had like
the guy who created bob's burgers you
have adam conover they're all part of
this team called old english and they
were like
so proud of themselves for being the
first people to do online sketch you go
back and watch the sketches they are no
funnier
or no better produced than the sketches
that were made later but all of them
have these huge careers now
donald glover was was part of derek
comedy they were making like
simple simple stuff with ellie kemper
and bobby moynihan and all these people
are famous
and they were just replaced the right
time and we got there a decade too late
i love it listen and all these people
have gotten to where they are and have
been able to stay there because they can
back their stuff up they're super
talented i mean sure
nobody's gonna say donald glover's not
super talented but i'll i'll be there
i'll tell myself to go there
if i could go back in time i guess i
should just like since i
promised this um so on my favorite trip
i ever went on
um was with my girlfriend we went to to
london
and uh for her birthday gift i got us
tickets to
it was really a gift for both of us i
got a tickets to harry potter and the
cursed child
do not see that play that play is trash
it sucks
it sucks we both kind of like the
production of it
because they do magic on stage like the
actors in it are incredible that they're
able to pull us up but the story
in my opinion ruins harry potter and it
made me like harry potter less
and i we both grew up with harry potter
we're huge potterheads
and like seeing this play it was also
just a stressful day i stupidly read the
tickets wrong
and i like made us miss the first 10
minutes
i was super stressed out those first 10
minutes provided the context for the
rest that's why you guys
honestly they do we watched it on a
video in the lobby and i'm like this is
better than everything but like oh
man it's such a a trash thing but hey
here's the deal i used to think about
this all the time if i could go back in
time and change things like
go to a different college go to a
different high school and i used to be
that nostalgic
person who would like replay events in
the past if i'd done things differently
but honestly since
meeting the love of my life i have
switched from someone who is nostalgic
and to someone who's just future
thinking i'm like if anything went
differently i might not have met her
right and that would suck my life would
be not can you imagine the stress can
you imagine the stress of going back in
time and being like
eric you have to be here at this time to
meet this person
otherwise everything is [ __ ] like
that's a lot of stress to put on a
person
yeah and i i don't know if you talk to
people who have who are lucky to find
someone like that
like they wouldn't change a thing no
matter every bad thing you went through
you wanted to just thank god that things
worked out the way they did i feel like
we should say because we're not monsters
we would absolutely tell our young
selves to prevent 911. uh of course well
of course we're not monsters
that should have been both versions
immediately well first of all we'll
prevent 911 but then also go to the
comedy scene in la i'm gonna
dick that should be the first thing i
said so
for both of us and both of us kids in
school look
i don't care if you're trying to figure
out uh cosigns and angles in geometry
class
you drive up to boston logan airport
and then you tackle that terrorist from
getting on that plane my sixth grade
would be like i'm in sixth grade you go
talk to the government and i'm like no
you have to do this
things are going to get nuts next year
you have to go first the whole world
will change yeah i mean and honestly
this line of thought hector is even
worse like we should have told ourselves
to prevent
covet for like covenant's been even
worse disaster than 9 11 was
like but i don't know how you can
prevent my selfishness my selfishness is
like
tell my kid self to like go prevent
chris farley from dying like that
save one guy chris farley just save one
guy just say one
the world would pretty much be the same
but he's around so that's better
yeah well this has been one of my
favorite episodes a big question hector
it's been so great to go through
all the different i think we hit pretty
much every time travel story if you have
a question
of one we didn't cover ask us we could
probably fit uh in in one of those eight
categories and hopefully we'll have more
categories of time travel
as the future reaches forward if there
is a future
well uh reminder that you can join us on
our official discord by going to patreon
patreon.com slash new rockstars you can
get an audio version of the show by
subscribing to new rockstars big
question wherever you get your podcast
send us
your big questions on twitter using the
question follow me at evos follow hector
at hector is funny and he is funny
you're you're not gonna regret following
hector it's it's always a laugh uh
following him on all social media and be
sure to uh
check out correcta mundo on the el rey
network that looks
hector yeah thank you so much we're able
to do a fun show from home and hopefully
people like it and hopefully we get to
do more it's lots of uh
i'm learning a lot i thought i knew
about movies and in doing a movie trivia
show
you learn a lot a bunch of weird cool
funny awesome stuff
so it's going to be great when uh people
get to uh to check it out yeah
absolutely check that out and be sure to
follow new rockstars on social subscribe
here on youtube to get too much
information on all the stuff you care
about
see you in another life brother
[Music]
you